okay former interim Democratic National
Committee Chair Donna Brazile has joined
Fox News there's a case to be made that
appearing where the opposition is and
disagreeing with them and their bad
ideas is this is a good thing to do
because you might convince people and I
get that I've appeared on Fox News
before I know that they're going to give
me bad lighting and the lower microphone
audio level and not give me time to talk
and debate me two on one instead of one
on one as promised but I've done it
because my calculation was it's better
than simply not appearing maybe I can
convince someone so I get that argument
the problem of Donna Brazile former DNC
chair joining fox news is that it's
reinforcing this sort of establishment
plus establishment corporate plus
corporate status quo that is responsible
for so many of the problems that we have
in American society in American politics
and in American media Fox News's total
corporate media right-wing corporate
media the DNC is what I call Democrats
Inc and Donna Brazile wrote an op-ed on
the Fox News website yesterday defending
her decision to join Fox News as an
analyst where she said quote it concerns
me as it does the majority of good
Americans that our national debate has
become hostile and disrespectful we no
longer simply agree to disagree
too often we demonize the intentions of
others our lines of communication are
frayed if not broken will I agree with
my fellow commentators at Fox News
probably not but I will listen will I
question some of their assertions about
hardworking Americans low-income people
and issues like climate change
absolutely but I will do so with
civility and respect making the case is
Donna Brazile that in the interest of
the battle of ideas carried out
respectfully and in the interest of
having civil debate
she believes that it is better for her
to participate in the completely skewed
apologia for the trump administration
taking place on Fox News the
- opted not to participate the problem
here is that she's not actually being
brought on to Fox News to engage in that
battle of ideas in a genuine way she is
not being brought to Fox News because
Fox News wants to encourage
depolarization by getting respectful
debate going between left and right she
is as a contributor providing cover to
Fox News as we say it allows them to say
we're not merely the propaganda arm of
the Trump White House we hired a
professional Democrat for crying out
loud so individually Fox News
appearances for any leftist or Democrat
make sense that's not my concern
my concern is that the big picture here
is that when Fox News brings people like
Donna Brazile in it's a controlled and
limited dissent that they have sort of
preemptively approved and I know I say
this very often it applies to Shepard
Smith and it applies to Chris Wallace
and whoever else sometimes makes sense
on fox news Fox News has a calculated
amount of dissent and diversity of
opinion they're not hiring Donna Brazile
to tell her what to say anymore than RT
tells their anchors and hosts what to
say they are hired because they've
already passed the audition in terms of
filling a role that fox or RT or CNN or
whoever have decided is acceptable to
the broader narrative so you know we
talk about this quite a bit on the
program a pat she is going to be brought
on to play pro DNC cheerleader in a safe
controlled and limited way she's not
going to question the system she's not
going to question the power of
organizations like the DNC and the RNC
and how they've sort of co-opted this
duopoly that we have in the political
system she's not going to question how
media consolidation has allowed so few
companies to control so many eyeballs
and attention it's a safe way to create
controlled descent and that's the
problem I have with it yeah I think
she'll play the role as the weak
Democrat
a strong woman I'm sorry strong woman
similar to the role that Juan Williams
played and Alan Colmes played but at the
end of the day I don't think that Donna
Brazile should be able to be a
contributor on any news outlet not Fox
News or MSNBC or CNN because while
working for a CNN she did leak debate
questions to Hillary Clinton and that
just goes against any sort of
journalistic ethics absolutely no
journalistic integrity
luckily Fox News is not going to be
hosting any of the Democratic debates in
the 2020 election but still I don't
think it's the right move at all to hire
her well she did what she did was wrong
with leaking the questions she wasn't
doing it in her role as a journalist of
course I think it's important but what
Pat points out is interesting because
Fox News guest spent last election
slamming Donna Brazile for passing
debate topics and debate questions to
Hillary Clinton and now they're hiring
her and she's working for them so bottom
line this is the epitome of the
corporate media political lobbying
industrial complex in the flesh it's
horrible and it's getting worse and
worse in terms of what we can expect for
2020 election coverage send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
one of today's david pakman show
sponsors is simple habit an app that
provides a massive library of really
excellent 5 minute guided meditations
they're letting everybody in our
audience use it completely free for one
week when you go to simple habit comm
slash Pakman we've talked a lot on the
program about the growing scientific
evidence pointing to the benefits of
meditation and what really sets simple
habit apart is the variety of guided
meditations that they offer more than
2,000 made for many different issues
that you may be dealing with if you need
help falling asleep if you have anxiety
that you're dealing with if you want to
be more productive during the day they
have meditations specifically tailored
for certain times of day like when
you're waking up or your commute to work
or when you've just gotten home from
work I'm a huge advocate of meditation
myself I've really enjoyed integrating
simple habit into my day and each
meditation takes just five minutes and
they're very easy to
valo maybe you want to feel more
grounded before you start your day at
work or at school maybe you want to keep
your mind a little more clear so that
it's easier to accomplish your goals or
you just want a calmer more peaceful
experience throughout your day simple
habit can help you get there it just won
the 2018 Google Play award for best
well-being app it's available on Android
iOS and web browser and you can try it
completely free for a week check it out
go to simple habit comm slash Pakman
I've put a link down below underneath
the video